the lasers seem awfully close to the
large american flag what if there's a
draft
sure leave these cameras operational but
shoot the others with utter snot
makes total sense morty's laser cannon
is aimed upward but by the time the beam
takes out a bell and liberty it has
managed to shift trajectory enough to
cause me to send every possible person
place or thing that was in the line of
this plot shot
also with weapons like that it almost
makes you wonder why taking out any of
the other decoy families or sperm
monsters in previous episodes was a big
deal at all
it was a trojan horse morty never trust
the french that's where i seized
once again all kinds of is going down at
smith's house and there are no nosy
neighbors to be seen
as anyone that works on this show lived
in the suburbs there'd be like a watch
party barbecue going on next door with
at least 20 to 30 people in attendance
there'd probably even be a bounce house
rented to keep the kids occupied
well happy thanksgiving to me
celebrating yourself
can't wait to see what a shimmer does to
my prostate shimmering your prostate
i don't even know what that means but
certainly it's sinful synchronized
digital exposition
sink digital position coop not on
thanksgiving how would she know who was
calling coop does he have a specific
vibration pattern for turkey time
that little race car driver you got
bacon in your belly what world you want
him rearing up in parental
predestination
what happened to the clothes they were
wearing did they meld into the skin of
the turkey because when they get turned
back into humans later they're no longer
wearing the clothes
yeah yeah it's cartoon blah blah blah
but have you watched this channel before
all due respect sir i know flesh when i
see it those flesh covered
robots should buy us some time but where
did rick get the flesh
you know what some things are okay to be
left unsaid i'll still send it for lack
of explanation but i'll be okay not
knowing about rick's leatherface
practices ship
go stealth but only after flying
directly overhead so we can clearly see
where you are in relation to your
mission
and forget about asking how the ship
escaped the bubble back home unnoticed
we don't ask those kinds of obvious plot
hole questions anymore
huh turkey marines the president came to
play but you knew this already right
i mean you did the entire expositional
plan thing and even showed fully armed
marine who won't recognize me
so why a shock let it be known that it
cannot be an official episode of rick
and morty until a questionable egg dish
has been placed on their dining room
table
that's weird id chips for fincher and
rodriguez are glitching
yeah super weird that you've not been
monitoring them the entire time
you've turned men into turkeys people
watch their vitals
wearing heels on a lawn also wearing
socks with heels
on the lawn here comes dipsh right on
schedule
nothing can go wrong now aside from
things immediately going wrong
i'm curious how the original plan would
have gone from here in order to
be pardoned rick would have to be the
selected turkey how does he plan to
stand out how would he have ensured that
he was going to be selected
i know it's not sexual favors turkeys
are notoriously selfish lovers
hold your positions as a feeding friend
blueberries have been available in this
dish for any of the birds to eat at any
point so why would
their sudden presence on the ground
initiate a food frenzy i hate to be
morbid but if you use the angle of the
gun barrels as a guide
every bird in this pit should be dead
now sir we are losing the mental game
down here
the mental game i think your bigger
issue is that someone up the chain
forgot to mention there were people
inside turkeys in this chamber and that
all machine guns should be turned off
because bird stomachs are just filled
with air so when you punch them
whatever is inside just cannons outward
super scientific
does anyone find it suspicious that the
laboratory now only has six turkafire
thingamajigs
they didn't know two of their own
wouldn't be returning did they but why
does this turkey look anything like the
president when it's transformed the pill
was simply a transmitter assigned to the
president there was no mention of it
being dna encoded and why would it be
look at this dumb piece of sh earlier
humans had no issue communicating with
the marines in turkey form but
now they can't understand the president
sound like a load of turkey
to me so to be clear the president
planned to straight up murder rick and
morty for charring a little piece of the
constitution and activating a war
machine that he doesn't actually care
about in the first place
i know i know questions like this matter
about as much as questioning fire under
the ocean in a spongebob episode but
still
why is there fire under the ocean i
thought we already rehumanized all the
turkified marines forgetting fincher and
rodriguez i am selling new york
to france and giving all of the money
to congress i want to send the idea that
these tactics would prove to be this
simple but sadly i'm more inclined to
believe they really are
this simple that's right murmur
and when you're done get me some pants
perhaps the most confusing part of this
episode is how rick managed to turn the
president
back into a human without a lab we skip
over any transformation explanation
entirely and you just
know that wherever they went had
something that would have worked for
clothing but i guess if you have a
you really just wanted to swing around
there is more bare ass in this episode
than both boss baby movies combined
also why does rick randomly have suits
to fit the president there won't be a
single bird left in dc
something birds aren't real has been
telling us the whole time i can't stop
looking at these two this man's torso is
longer than hers but her legs are longer
than his and the circular footrests are
down so low they both appear to either
be very short or the stools aren't made
correctly and
wow his hair grew back quickly sir we've
got rick and morty coming in what
appears to be an
unlicensed star wars adapt or as the
millennials say
at-80 oh yes the is die-hardy christmas
movie argument for star wars fans except
it's even more annoying
pilgrims of the corn i wish to explode
this works oh they love each other
perplexing sure but even more confusing
maybe the fact that the far superior
race of aliens willingly returns to
their secret chamber to re-enter some
sort of cryogenic status so they can be
called upon again at some point in the
future by a civilization that they do
not have to support
kids
i don't know what the hell that is but
i'll lick it anyway
this place is worse than on my shoe
locate the president's chip
roger roger what's our vector victor i'm
here today at the uh
on because the earth has been attacked
my military advisers at the pentagram
have managed to do the impossible i need
your clothes
your boots and your motorcycle wear
three across the bed
not a stitch of clothes on i made it to
shell city
and i beat the cyclops and i rode the
hassle off
and i brought the crown back whoa
i think my life is like flashing in
front of my eyes